okay why don't i get started um
so
okay what would what have we been doing
um so last time we considered a bunch of
uh procedures for testing properties of
various automata and grammars
the acceptance problem for dfas
for anaphase
the acceptance problem which is really
the generation problem for context-free
grammars
and emptiness problems for dfas and and
and context-free grammars
and also um
we looked we we showed that atm is
turning recognizable like there's a
question here in the chat already about
that yes we did show that that was the
universal turing machine that we
presented at the end that's what shows
that atm is turning recognizable
um
we mentioned that uh it's not atm is not
decidable uh which we promised we will
prove today and we will do so okay so
that is the plan
um proving atm is undecidable
and we'll introduce the method for doing
that called the diagonalization method
i will also show the complement of atm
is
uh turing on rec unrecognizable even
though atm itself is recognizable the
complement is not
and
then we will introduce another method
called the reducibility method for
showing other problems are not decidable
and give a one example of another
problem which is not decidable assuming
we have time to get to it if not we will
uh
uh delay that part until uh next
tuesday's lecture
all right acceptance problem for uh
touring machines uh so just um
as i mentioned we showed that atm um
which is the language of turing machines
and inputs where the machine accepts the
input
um
we showed that was recognizable we
claimed it was decidable today we're
going to prove it's not decidable
all right now the method
uh that
uh we're going to use um which is really
the only method out there um for proving
uh um
some pro you know a problem was
undecidable is the decoder
diagonalization method i mean ultimately
we're going to show the reducibility
method as well but it really depends on
having already shown some other problem
undecidable
via
the diagonalization method so ultimately
everything hinges on the diagonalization
method which is really all we have um
and uh so
to
uh introduce the diagonalization method
i'm going to
make a bit of a
digression into a
uh branch of mathematics called set
theory or
it's part of mathematical logic where
the method of diagonalization was first
uh
conceived of uh back in the late 19th
century by a mathematician called georg
cantor
and cantor was considering the problem
of how do you compare
the relative sizes of infinite sets
you know for finite sets um
the
uh
the problem of comparing somebody said
that the cantor went crazy that is that
is true um
and maybe i i i don't know why he went
crazy but
um he um he did go uh he had some mental
problems unfortunately um
and so
so how do we compare the sizes of sets
in general if they're finite sets we can
just count them up
we can say oh this set has
uh 11 elements and the other set has uh
10 elements so the 11 one with 11 is
bigger or if they both have 11 they're
the same size well that's not going to
work for infinite sets because you can't
count them up um
and so he had cantor had the following
idea for comparing the sizes of infinite
sets
um and that was
basically um to see whether you can have
a function
that would map
from one set to the other set with
certain properties
and those properties are um called
traditionally well i mean
in the past have been called the
one-to-one and onto properties for the
function i'll tell you what that means
um but the concept is very simple um so
a one-to-one function is one a function
that's mapping from a to b those are the
two sets whose sizes we're trying to
compare
and
uh the function being one to one just
means that there are no collisions if
you have two different elements of a
they're never going to map onto the same
element of b
so two different elements of a always
map onto two different elements of b
so that's the one-to-one property it's
also called injective um
and um the other property is called onto
or surjective um which is that the range
of f has to be all of b so you're not
allowed to miss any elements b you have
to hit everything
um
and when you have the both of those
properties it the function is called the
one-to-one correspondence or a bijection
also
okay um
now uh another way of looking at i don't
want to make this overly more
complicated than it needs to be it just
simply means that two sets are
considered to be the same size if we can
match up the elements with one set with
elements of the other set you just pair
them up
you know for example well
if you look have finite sets um that
into that idea that informal idea just
works exactly as you would expect you
know for example if we have two sets
here's a set of puppies here's a set of
kittens
um
now we want to show that those two sets
have the same size we could count them
up as i mentioned and see that there are
six elements in both
but it's counting up does not work for
infinite sets
so
um we can just match up the elements of
the the puppies with the kittens
and then we know they're we have the
same number of puppies as kittens
okay now that has the advantage of it
making sense when you have infinite sets
so we're just going to extend that idea
and apply it to infinite sets too and
then we'll have a notion of what it
means for two infinite sets to have the
same size
and you might wonder what do you get you
know are all infinite sets of the same
size when you use this notion or or not
what happens um well some strange things
do happen but there actually are quite
some interesting um
uh structure there that uh that emerges
so if um
so anyway
i don't want to rush on uh questions on
any of this if you want to uh
quick question this hopefully was not
too hard but i want to make sure
everybody's together with me on it so we
can pop in uh
i'll give a few seconds for a chat if
you have any uh questions
um
the rain the range of the set is all of
the elements that you hit as you look at
the different possible elements of a so
all of the things that f hits the
standard notion of range of a function
um
so the range of s f has to be equal to b
you have to hit everything
um right uh
can you think of a one-to-one
correspondent says relabeling yeah i'm
not sure that's helpful but yes you can
think of as a re-labeling of the
elements in a sense but uh yeah
i just think of it as a matching up
um all right so let's move on um
so uh
coming out of this notion of sets of
being of the same size there was this
notion of countable sets as we'll see in
a minute um
so
let's do an example
let's take the set of natural numbers
you know one two three four dot dot dot
and the set of integers
which includes the natural numbers but
but also the negative numbers in zero um
so the
natural numbers are typically referred
to as n the
integers are typically referred to as z
and
how do we
what do we think of the relative sizes
of um
n and z
well n is a subset of z it's a proper
subset of c so you might at first glance
think that z is larger and they're not
really going to be of the same size
but it actually it turns out that
there's a very simple way
you know the arithmetic and the
properties of infinite sensor can be a
little bit surprising and there is a way
of matching up all of the elements of z
with elements their own elements of n um
and so you can show that as uh
following that definition that these two
sets are in fact of the same size so
let's just quickly go that goes make
sure you see that
um
so here is n
here is z i'm going to write down a
table which shows how they match up and
here's the function f of n that i'm
going to be describing that's the um the
one-to-one correspondence
and so here are the natural numbers
dot one through seven dot dot dot and
here are the elements of z that i'm
gonna be matching up this is how the
function is working so one i'm gonna you
know f of one is gonna be zero f of two
is gonna be minus one f of three is
gonna be one
um and i'm just giving you a way to
match up each of the natural numbers
with with integers
so that every single integer has its own
natural number and vice versa um
[Music]
so four goes to minus two five goes to
two six goes to minus three seven goes
to three and then minus four and then
four minus five then five and so on
you're clearly going to cover all of the
integers in this way and each of the
natural numbers is going to have its own
integer and there's never going to be
any collisions there's never going to be
two natural numbers assigned to the same
integer so this is meets the uh the
conditions of a one-to-one
correspondence and shows that the
natural numbers and the um and the
integers have the same size
uh following this definition um
okay let's do one that's slightly
more
complicated um and perhaps slightly more
surprising
which is that if you consider all of the
rational numbers
and um then they have the same that is a
collection even though the rational
numbers seem to be much richer and
more numerous than the integers from
this perspective they have the same size
and for the simplicity of my uh
my presentation i'm going to consider
only the positive rational numbers which
i'm going to write as q plus
so those are all of the positive
rational numbers that can be expressed
as a ratio of two natural numbers
and um i'm going to show that there is a
one-to-one correspondence between the
rations between these positive rational
numbers and and the natural numbers
okay so
um
here i'm going to again make a table
just as i did up uh up above um
so comparing the natural numbers and the
positive rational numbers
and
to do that i'm going to write down over
here on the side just to help you see
how i'm getting this table
a table a separate table that can that
has all of the rational number positive
rational numbers appearing you know in
kind of a nicely organized way um here
are all the rational numbers here that
have one as a numerator that have two as
a numerator and and so on and going
through across the columns the different
denominators
um so it's the the numbers inside here
represent all of the different rational
numbers and so whatever rational number
you have
m over n
um
that's going to appear down the nth row
in the nth column
that number is going to appear so
they're all going to show up
and i'm going to use this
table here to fill out this function
um
so uh
here are all the natural numbers and the
way i'm going to assign
the
rational numbers to appear over here is
i'm just going to work my way in from
the corner
and i'm going to do that by kind of
doing layers so first i'll take the one
in this
this number here in this corner then
i'll do these three that surround it and
then these guys that's around that and
these guys sort of in shells going
around the previous ones that i've
already covered
okay so
let me illustrate that
so here's one over one my first rational
number that i'm going to enter then to
the table
appearing right over there so next i'm
going to go 2 over 1
that's going to appear in the table over
there
now we have 2 over 2. now that's
actually a little bit uh problematic
because 2 over 2 has already been done
um and if we put that in
uh because 2 over 2 equals 1 over 1
they're both the equal to the rational
number one
so if we put two over two in this table
over here then we would no longer have
the one-to-one property because both one
and three would be mapping to the same
point um so we're just going to simply
skip over two over two
um
i'll show that as kind of graying it out
so we're not gonna
we're not gonna add that one onto the
table onto my function
um
so but so we'll skip over that we'll go
to one over two which is um has not been
seen before
and then we're just going to continue
doing the same thing now going to this
next shell out here
three over one
three over two
three over three
same thing i'm going to skip over that
one
2 over 3
1 over 3. i hope you're getting the idea
um so i'm not going to fill this
together i ran out of room to
put fill out this table some more but
just to look at how the process is going
to continue here i would get 4 over 1.
now 4 over 2
again is the number we've previously
seen because that's the that's the
rational number 2. we saw that up here
when we had 2 over 1 so we're going to
have to skip that one
4 over 3 four over four
that was going to skip
three or four and so on
okay so by uh following this procedure
i'm going to be able to define this
function now this function is not
particularly nice in terms of having a
an elegant closed form but it is a
the total legitimate function in the
sense of being a mapping from
natural numbers to
the positive rational numbers
and it has the one-to-one correspondence
property
so it pairs up each of the
natural numbers with each of the um
uh positive rational numbers um they
each get their own
mate in a sense and so that shows that
the rational numbers despite the fact
that they're dense and they have all
sorts of very sort of more much bigger
seaming they really and from this
perspective of the sizes of the sets
they have the same size as the
natural numbers do and so with that it
suggested
the following definition that a set is
countable
if it has the same size as the natural
numbers or it's finite
from this perspective we're going to be
focusing on infinite sets uh but yeah
countable or countably infinite
sometimes people say uh if it has the
same size as the natural numbers or
otherwise you have to include the finite
sets as well and countable means you can
just sort of go through the the sets the
the elements of the set kind of
as a list
so you can count them the first one the
second one the third one the fourth one
dot dot dot and once you can do that and
that counting is going to hit everything
then you know um you can match them you
can pair them up with the natural
numbers and so therefore you have a
countable set okay um
[Music]
so as we've shown
both z
the integers and the positive rational
numbers are countable sets
okay now
you might think that well since we're
allowing ourselves to do something as
arbitrary in a way as this kind of a
function
to match up the natural numbers with
whatever set you're trying to um
to measure
that every set is going to be countable
if you think about it that way because
it seems like you're allowing two too
too many possibilities and that all the
infinite sets are going to end up being
the same size as the natural numbers
well that isn't in fact is not true
um
and i don't know i i i
can't or as the one who discovered that
um i don't know if that was surprising
or not um but uh it is kind of uh
interesting i think that there are
different sizes of infinities um
and uh so uh we're gonna now take a look
and see uh that but i want to again um
i want to uh stop and make sure we're
all together can we always find a closed
formula for f somebody's asking me um
i don't know
for this particular f uh
you probably could but it would probably
be very messy um
um but in general that's not a
requirement
having a closed form for the for the
mapping function any function is allowed
as long as it's a one-to-one
correspondence
um
are we all together on this is this are
we comfortable with the notion of
some infinite sets
having the same size as the natural
numbers and therefore we're going to
call them countable sets and we're going
to show some other sets are going to
have um more elements they're going to
be uncountable they're going to be
beyond
strictly speaking strictly larger sets
in the sense that we won't be able to
put them into a one-to-one
correspondence with the integers um so
then the smallest infinity yes n is the
smallest um
smallest one so
any infinity is going to have um
you know you can always i don't think
you even need it you need a special
you know you can always
and whenever you have an
internet collection you can always find
a subset which is going to be
a countable subset uh so it's uh
and is going to be the smallest of the
infinities but there are bigger ones
all right why don't we move on
okay so um
the example of a set that we will show
is not countable an uncountable set as
we call it um is the
uh set of real numbers which you i
you know
we all know what these are i hope uh
these are all of the numbers that you
can express by possibly infinite decimal
representations like pi or e square root
of two
um or on any of the other familiar ones
you know um rational numbers are also
members of uh
are also count as real numbers and
integers too um
and so
uh but you know there are these
additional numbers that you can get by
uh
decimal expansions which may not be
rational
um
and that collection even though in some
ways it looks somewhat similar to the
rational numbers um the real numbers i
hope i said that right the real numbers
um uh the the uh which is the set i'm
considering here the ones with the
infinite decimal expansions they
actually are much larger
um
so
um
the theorem is and this was discovered
by kantor um that uh r is an uncountable
set
and the reason why i'm introducing this
is um besides that i think it's
interesting um
uh
and has some some relation uh to uh the
kinds of things we're doing but it's
really for the purposes right now is to
introduce this method called
diagonalization
um
okay uh that's we're gonna use later on
again but this is the first time it
appeared
so we're going to
use a proof by contradiction in order to
show that r the collection of real
numbers
is uncountable and we'll assume for
contradiction that r is countable
okay
um
so
if we assume that r is countable it
means we have by definition a one to one
correspondence from the natural numbers
to the real numbers
okay so we can match up
all of the natural numbers with
uh the real numbers in a one-to-one and
onto fashion so we can pair up the
natural numbers with the real numbers
and we will cover all of the real
numbers by doing that and we can make a
table
just like i did before
here it is
um
and you can fill this out with all of
the real numbers
and um
that was what the assumption means and
i'm going to show you that that's
impossible something is going to go
terribly wrong if you do that
um now uh
you might disagree you might be
surprised you might think well
uh professor sipser is wrong um you know
that i'm gonna work on this overnight
and forget the rest of my classes and
i'm gonna come up with a list of
uh all the real numbers i'm gonna fill
them out here and show that that's
impossible um so let's say
hypothetically just for my example's
sake um here is the list that you came
up with um
so you know you had to match up
something with the one let's say e had
to that was a special case so you're
gonna stick that with one and then pi
came out to be the number that you you
connected up with uh two you wanna see
what i'm doing here i'm making a list
i'm trying to make my one my
correspondence my matching up between
the natural numbers and my real numbers
that i'm hypothesizing to exist for a
contradiction
so three
i i don't know three is gets connected
to zero i'm making this up obviously uh
not on the spot i wrote the slide you
know uh yesterday but uh here's a square
root of two showing up for whatever
reason here is one seventh
here is some other number which i'll be
interested if you recognize that one
that's a that's a subtle one um
this is one point two three four one
point yeah some some familiar looking
sequence here and whatever it is
whatever it is this is what you came up
with you claim that this is to work as
uh very good you somebody got it
it's i to the eighth power but let's not
get hung up on that please um
i to the either power oddly enough can
be seen as a real number under you know
if you define the uh
imaginary exponentiation
uh which is weird but anyway
let's uh let's not get too distracted um
so here's my list of numbers my real
numbers that i've matched up in my table
here with the natural numbers
now something's go i claim something
goes wrong what goes wrong i'm going to
show you that you actually
uh did not
do as you claimed
that there's actually um at least one
number that's missing from this list and
i'll exhibit that number i'm going to
show you what that number is i'm going
to explicitly come up with a number and
show you that there's that number it's
missing from the list um so here
it's going to be a number x
x is the x is the one that's missing
so how am i going to get x
so x well i'm going to start it off with
zero point and then i'm going to fill
out the rest of the places and how am i
going to get those places i'm going to
look at the table here
so i want to look at to get my first
digit after the decimal point of x
i'm going to look at the first digit
after the decimal point of the very
first number
so i take the first number look at the
first digit after the decimal point
and which happens to be a 7
and the number i'm going to put in for x
is not going to be 7 it's going to be
anything except 7.
let's say
8. um
for my next digit of x
i'm going to look at
so my second digit of x i'm going to
after the decimal everything's going to
be after the decimal point now uh so i'm
not going to keep saying that i'm going
to look at the second digit of the
second number uh which is a four
uh after the decimal point um
uh
there it is
and for the second digit of x i'm going
to use something which is
anything besides four five
i have some flexibility here um so i
could have used six i could have used
seven
i'm going for those of you who have seen
this before who are gonna nitpick on me
i'm gonna stay away from nine and zero
just because there are some little um
edge cases that arise there which i
don't want to get into because i don't
think it's interesting for this argument
um but since i have some flexibility i'm
going to avoid zeros and nines probably
just nine is all i really need and then
um
the argument is just going to work fine
okay
so uh the next digit is a zero
uh for the third digit of the third
number is a zero the third digit of x is
going to be anything except for zero be
a one
then i have a two here
anything except a two
six
uh then five anything except a five a
one a nine anything except a nine an
eight
and so on there's an eight
there's a two and dot dot dot i'm just
gonna keep doing that
and i'm gonna say
you missed that number whatever it is
but that number it's a that's a number
after i'm all done it's going to be the
decimal representation of something
and that number uh i claim
is absent from the table
and you might say well
you know it's really there
um it's just on the
um
23rd row
you just didn't get to it on your slide
but it's there well i'm going to say i
know it's not in the 23rd row because it
differs from the number in the 23rd row
at the 23rd digit
because i constructed it that way
this number is designed
explicitly to be different from each of
the numbers that's on the list
okay so it can't be on the list because
it's been constructed to be different
from each of them in at least one place
so it's i think this is a beautiful
argument and it shows that
uh no matter how you try to come up with
a one-to-one correspondence you're going
to fail you know you might say oh you
know like
you know just one number you know it did
so much hard work and missing just one
number can i get partial credit
you know and put this one on the list
now i fix it no obviously there are many
many numbers that are missing if you put
this one on the list i'm going to
construct another number that was
missing
so
um this is uh
you know
there's just not no possibility of
fixing this and in fact you know the um
the real numbers are
are uncountable cannot be matched up
with the natural numbers and there's
nothing
it can't even come it doesn't even come
close um
so um
here's summary what i just said
um f is not a one-to-one correspondence
no matter what you try to do you can't
come up with a one-to-one correspondence
so that's the contradiction
okay so that proves that
r is uncountable
okay and that's why by the way we call
this a diagonalization because we're
going down this diagonal here that's
where the term that's where the name has
come from
okay um
so i i'm happy to
okay that's it uh
somebody's asking me
i'm actually i have a
um
is it here i can't remember it's here i
have a uh check-in coming about this and
somebody is kind of um anticipating that
by asking uh the the actual rather
famous question about there being a
possible infinity in between
the natural numbers and the real numbers
we know the real numbers now are bigger
than the natural numbers but is there
something that's in between i mean this
is a very very famous problem um
uh which i'll talk about you know when
we get to our check-in which is coming
up
um
well somebody is objecting just the way
i've defined x using this procedure that
really really can't in a sense state
you know but it x is a number x is the
result of
what what this procedure is it's you
know following this procedure we're
converging on some particular value and
so that is the value um if you want you
know we can make a more precise way of
determining i mean i so i we don't have
the flexibility of choosing the way i
did in my example we can make a precise
procedure for coming up with these
digits but
i don't think there's anybody thinks
there's anything
that's um
there's any shortcoming in this argument
in terms of the way we're defining x
it's i i think it's worth understanding
this
because it's really going to set the
groundwork for our proof that atm is
undecidable which is a little i think
perhaps slightly more abstract in a way
um in the way it sort of comes across
i'm going to try to can make connect the
two
but uh i think it's helpful to
understand at least this argument
because this argument is kind of
diagonalization in its kind of most
raw form
all right i think we're good um so let
why don't we continue then um
so there are a number of corollaries
that follow from the statement that the
real numbers is uncountable um
uh
first of all if you let script l be the
collection of all languages if you want
to consider over some particular
alphabet that's fine but that's not
going to be really uh
you know important for this uh
point that i'm trying going to make so
uh l
uh script l is the collection of all
languages um so every subset
of sigma star
every subset of sigma star is a language
um so look at all those possible subsets
um so that includes you know 0 to the k
1 to the k plus every other language you
can ever think of and more all possible
languages
um so that
the collection of all languages is
uncountable
there's uncountably many different
languages out there
i don't want to belabor this point you
can just take this if you don't quite
follow the the quick argument i'm going
to make here but um
uh you can make a correspondence
one-to-one correspondence from all
languages to the reals
so that each language gets its own real
number
and the way i'm going to think about
that let's put the real numbers into
binary form
and if you imagine here being sigma star
all of the possible strings of sigma
star
you know written out in their standard
order
um and now if you have a language here a
it's just some arbitrary language so
that's going to have some of the strings
of um of sigma star appearing like zero
is appearing but one is not appearing
zero zero is appearing in zero one but
not these three
um and i'm gonna associate to a
my language
some real number in binary by putting in
a zero in the decimal representation or
the binary representation i should say
um
for that
string
if it's not there and a one if it is
there
um and so a real number because there's
infinite many infinitely many yes no
choices
in the binary representation can
represent a language because of each of
the yes no choices of a string being
present or not i'm going to put a one
for when the string is present the zero
when it's not present so each
uh language has its own real number and
each real number is going to be
associated to its own uh language here
i'm restricting myself to real numbers
between zero and 1
that's not going to be an essential
point so let's not get hung up on that
so
[Music]
the
the fact that
the
the languages can be
uh
put into one-to-one correspondence with
the real numbers
um
shows that the collection of all
languages is also uncountable
now another
observation here another point worth
noting is that if you look at sigma star
itself
the strings
uh all possible strings that's a
countable set
the collection of all possible languages
is uncountable but the collection of all
possible finite strings
is countable because i can just list
them
here is my list of all possible strings
which you can put into a table if you
like to think of it matching up with the
natural numbers in that way
now i'm get i'm trying to make a point
here which is that
if you take am which is all possible
turing machines script m is all possible
turing machines the collection of all
possible turing machines is countable
there are only countably many different
turing machines
and you can argue that in all sorts of
messy different ways but i think the
most simple way to see that
is to think about each turing machine as
having a description
which is a string
so the collection of all descriptions of
turing machines is just a subset of
sigma star which we already know is
countable
and the subset of any countable set is
going to be countable
so
anyway
i think it's worth
remembering
that
the collection of all turing machines is
countable
um whereas the collection of languages
is uncountable and that tells you right
there
that some language is not decided
because there are more languages than
touring machines
we have uncountably many language only
countably many turing machines so that's
fewer turing machines than languages
there's no way to map all the languages
onto turing machines so there's going to
always be some languages that got
unmapped
um and so in particular there are going
to be some languages which are
undecidable there are going to be some
languages which are not touring
recognizable
and anything based on some automata kind
of um
definite definition process is going to
be some languages that you're not going
to be not going to be defining
um
okay now what this corollary shows you
that there is some language out there
which is not decidable what we're going
to show next is that there is a specific
language atm which is not decidable
okay and but first i think we have a
check-in coming up
and
let me give you a little bit of
background here because this is relevant
to this question that i got
about intermediate sized sets so
the question of whether there is a set
of size between the natural numbers and
the real knit numbers
strictly in between so bigger than the
natural numbers not the same size as the
natural numbers but not the same size as
the real numbers either
um but in between uh in size
um
that was hilbert's question number one
out of his list of 23 that i talked
about a few lectures back
it's interesting that he put it as
number one in that very privileged
special place
because i know hilbert was very
he felt that the understanding infinity
was a really central issue in
mathematics and that if we can't answer
a question like this we don't really
understand infinity um
uh you want to understand what kind of
sizes of infinities are there um we know
there's the real numbers bigger than the
than the natural numbers is there
something in between so fundamental
really um
but uh it was shown uh during the course
of the 20th century really in two
separate steps one in the 1930s by
girdle one in the early 1970s by cohen
that we can't answer this question by
using the standard axioms of mathematics
you know it's
the the answer can go either way
and it's both of them are consistent
with the axis of mathematics so you're
never going to be able to prove
that there is a set whose size is in
between
or that you or that there is no such set
it's just impossible to prove either
direct either way
using the standard axiom in mathematics
which actually is kind of remarkable um
and so my question for you is and this
is really a philosophical question not
one that um is directly and you need to
know about material in the course just i
think it's just a matter of your own
interest i hope you find it interesting
if you don't you pick a wren you can
just answer it randomly um
but um
what's going on here that we can't
answer that question about whether there
is a set of intermediate sides is it
because our axioms for mathematics are
inadequate
or
maybe there is no such thing as a
mathematical reality you can talk about
you know you know what's what's real
here what what what's the reality either
there is a set in between or not
if you imagine all of these things have
their own reality to them well then
there's going to be an answer and then
you would expect well maybe we could
find better axioms which will actually
give us that answer or you can say well
there is no reality
and um
you know it
infinite sets are kind of human
constructs anyway so we can make them
kind of play out any way we like
mathematicians argue about that to this
day um
and um it is as i say really it's a
philosophical question but just out of
curiosity let's see how you guys end up
uh deciding on that one um so here's the
poll
five seconds to go please vote
and uh we're going to end the polling
one two three now
all right here we go
so there's no right answer
um
i think if most mathematicians were
to um
i think the instinct of most logicians
especially i'm not sure our general
mathematicians really even care about
this question but logicians um
would probably have an instinct that
probably there are sets in between
there's no reason that there shouldn't
be
um
you know it seems kind of strange that
there should be this sort of jump uh
from the
natural numbers to the real numbers and
why nothing in between um
but um
it's uh
i don't think that question is really
settled
so
all right let's continue on i think we
are
um okay so we're gonna
um
a coffee break is coming in case you're
wondering so this is on my last slide
before then but this is an important
slide so please uh hold hold out
um
so here is our
uh promised theorem of the day
i'm going to show that atm is not
decidable the acceptance problem for
turing machines
and it's all going to be contained on
this one slide we're going to give a
proof by contradiction using
diagonalization
and we're going to assume some turing
machine h decides atm
and we're going to get a contradiction
so let's first of all make sure we
understand what h is doing
so h gets an input a turing machine and
an
input and h is going to be a decider so
it always halts
with an accept or a reject
it's supposed to accept if m accepts w
and reject if it doesn't so in other
words it's going to reject if m rejects
w either by whole by halting or by
looping
that's the job of h
and we're assuming we can do that
but we will see a contradiction occur
so the way we're going to do that
is is really kind of just one step here
in a way and we're going to use h to
construct another turing machine d
h is going to be a subroutine to d
we've already seen us doing that in the
past
d is going to do something a little
strange
just to just to warn you um
these input is just a turing machine no
in no w
and
what
d is going to do
using its subroutine h
is going to simulate h
on input
m comma the description of m now what is
that
well the description of m is just some
string
so what h is trying what it's asking h
uh to tell to answer is does m
accept
the string representing m's own
description
it's as if we're feeding m into itself
which seems like a totally twisted thing
to do
um
you might say
uh
you know
why would you ever feed a program into
itself
somebody's written cannibalism here
yeah kind of uh i said it's it's worse
because it's
not eating somebody else it's eating
himself
okay but
um
i claim
that we actually there are actual cases
in practice
where we do this
we feed programs into themselves
and uh the example that i know of where
this is done
is when you're making a compiler
you might want to make a compiler and
then written in the same language that
it's compiling and then you feed the
compiler into itself
they may say why even bother because
it's already obviously if once it's
running you don't need to
compile it again um but actually you
know an example where this was really
used
was when there was an optimizing
compiler i think for c uh written on
early unix machines
and the optimizing compiler for c was
written in c
so you would feed the optimizing
compiler
into the regular compiler first of all
now you had the um
compiler running
but it was unoptimized
so but now that it's the optimizing
compiler is running
you can feed the optimizing compiler
into that which is itself now you have
an optimized optimizing compiler
so it really makes
some there is a at least one case where
this has actually been done uh in
practice
um not that we really care this is a
theory class but just for fun to observe
that
so here h is trying to say well does n a
m end up accepting when it's fed
the description of itself
you know at least mathematically
speaking that's a reasonable uh thing to
ask
and then what
d is going to do when it gets the answer
back from h
h as a decider don't forget
is d is going to do the opposite
whatever h does it's going to accept if
h rejects and rejective h accepts
um so let's in summary let's pull this
together some
you know it's easy to understand in the
end what is d doing
d is going to accept d is also going to
be decided by the way so d d is always
going to either accept or reject
just the opposite of what h tells it to
do so d is going to accept
m
exactly when m doesn't accept m because
you know when m doesn't accept m
h is going to reject
um and so then d is going to accept so d
accepts m if and only if m doesn't
accept that that's exactly the condition
in which d accepts it
i think it's important to just step back
and make sure you understand this line
because we have only one line left
to get our contradiction
right are we together d accepts m if and
only if m doesn't accept m that's just
by the that way we've defined setup d
now
what we're going to do is feed in
instead of m to d and not some arbitrary
fee
we're going to use feed in d into d
and that is going to be our
contradiction because d is now going to
accept d if and only if d doesn't accept
e and that's certainly impossible
okay
that's our contradiction which proves
that h cannot exist and therefore atm is
undecidable
okay so we're done
except for the one point which is that
um
why is this a
diagonalization
and i think you can get that from the
following picture
if you imagine here writing down all
possible time i'm making i'm going to
make a table here here is a list of all
turing machines
okay uh including d which is a machine
which i
built
under the assumption that h exists so d
appears here somewhere but here are the
all the other turing machines and here
are all these descriptions of the turing
machines along the uh labeling all of
the columns
okay so these are the rows labeled these
are the column labels and inside i'm
going to tell you
uh the answer for whether a given
machine
accepts a given input
so for example m1 accepts its own
description but rejects the description
of m2 but accepts the description of m3
i don't know you know i'm obviously
making this up i don't know what m1 is
but just hypothetically that's what the
machine m1 does
um so i'm just filling out this table
and you know this is
d
uh h could get the answer to any of the
elements in this table because it can
test whether m4
um accepts the description of m3 so it
could h could fill out this table
so maybe m2 is a machine that always
rejects it's a very unfriendly rejecting
machine
m3 is a very friendly machine it accepts
all inputs and for its reject sum and
accepts other dot dot dot
now i want to look and see what does d
do
um
now based on the information i've
already given you we can understand what
d does
so for example what does d do when i
feed it the description of m1
what does d do
well we can look over here d accepts m
if and only if m doesn't accept m so d
is going to accept
um
m1 if and only if m1 does not accept m1
well m1 does accept m1
so d
does the opposite d rejects
so okay i'm highlighting here
d rejects because it's going to d is
going to do the opposite of what the
machine does on its own it on input
um so m2 on so d on m2 you have to look
what m2 does on m2 it rejects so d does
the opposite of that it accepts
and similarly
uh
you know all each one of these things
these answer is going to be the opposite
of what the machine does on its own
description
um just by virtue of the definition of
date
okay and so on so far so good
but the problem is what happens when d
is fed itself
because as you can see
you know um we're we're heading for
we're heading for trouble because this
is a diagonal down here
d is just one of the rows that diagonal
is going to
intersect that row at this point
and d is defined to be going to be doing
the opposite of what that element is but
it can't be the opposite of itself
okay and so that's that's the
contradiction
so i think you know where um
uh
i i'm gonna call us give us a little
break here um and then you can also text
me in the meantime we'll be happy to
answer some questions during during that
a little over four minutes to go so
let's see let me see if i can
answer your questions
okay what's so special about atm that
enables us to do this why can't we do
this on adfa for example
um so that's a good question i i i
and
the answer is that um
you know
you know in a sense
you know we can do this on dfa i mean i
i think this is perhaps a bit bit of a
stretch but you know dfas could not
answer adfa i mean we could prove that
in other ways as well you know by uh
because
you know we could use things like the
pumping lima and it's not clear even how
you formulate adf8
but what's important here is that the
um it's really the model talking about
itself
um that really is where the problem
comes up
so if you try to push this argument
through to show that adfa is not
decidable by touring machines you're
gonna fail
um
because you know we're starting off with
a turing machine and um i mean
i think i'm gonna confuse myself if i
try to just repeat it but um you're you
won't get a contradiction because the
turing machine is not a find out
automaton
um
okay um
will this argument get into self loops i
don't see why there was there is some
self-reference perhaps we're going to
talk about that a little later because
we're going to come back and revisit
this argument um
you know in a
in a week or so when we talk about the
recursion theorem which talks about
machines that can refer to themselves
but this is a little bit of a head
getting ahead of ourselves so
uh somebody's commenting on this
reminding them of the barber paradox if
you remember that the
which has some similarity you know the
there's a town in which uh there is a
barber which shaves every man who
doesn't shave themselves
which seems you know he's a very good
barber so there's some people who shave
themselves
and
all the rest the barber shavers uh the
question is does the barber shave
himself because he shaves only those men
who don't shave themselves so you got a
same kind of a contradiction there is a
there is a relationship there
um
so somebody wants to know where did we
use the decidability so we used the
decidability to come up with h
um
you know once we know that atm is
decidable then we have that h function
and then we can build d
um so that's where that's the the the
chain of that's the chain of reasoning
um
so you assume atm is decidable then you
have the decider
and then
called h and then you can build d um
somebody wants to see the previous slide
well
uh what part of this one do you want
uh
so i'll leave that up there why can't we
why can't we apply the proof that all
touring machines are countable to all
languages well because turing machines
have descriptions
languages general languages don't have
descriptions
and so that's uh why okay the candle has
burned to the to the bottom and it's
time to move on um
so now let's look at the
uh acceptance problem for kuwatama
i'll give you a q automaton an input
and i want to know does it accept the
input is that going to be decidable
and you have you have your choices it's
either yes
it is decidable because these are
similar to put down automata and apda is
decidable
or no because yes would con contradicts
results that we know at this point or we
don't have enough information to answer
the question
okay let's put that up
one second
all right
that's it ready going gone
uh so
yes the answer is uh well no
the answer is the indeed the answer is b
um
uh true that uh cubitamina are similar
to push on automata but all these atomic
are kind of similar to each other and
that's not going to be good enough
uh
well the homework has asked you to do is
to show that you can simulate turing
machines with q automata
so if you can answer the question about
whether the queue automata uh will
accept their input that would allow you
to be able to answer questions about
whether turing machines accept their
input and we just proved that's not
possible
so um
uh
it would get it be a contradiction if we
could answer
uh if we could decide a qa
now we have an example of an undecidable
language let's look at an example of an
unrecognizable language
now atm is not going to serve
that purpose because atm
um
[Music]
is
um
recognizable is turning recognizable as
we pointed out by the universal turing
machine
so uh atm is undecidable however how
about an unrecognizable language
for that we will see that the complement
of atm
will serve so the complement of atm
is
neither decidable nor even recognizable
that's not turing recognizable
and that's going to follow from a pretty
basic theorem that connects
recognizability and decidability that i
put up here on the screen
which is that if you have a language
where it and its complement are both
recognizable then the language turnout
turns out to be decidable in fact the
language and its complement are decided
but but being decidable is closed under
complement so that's something you
should be aware of
um
but being uh okay
we'll get to that in a minute but
uh if um
uh
so anyway so we have a language and it's
complement both recognizable how do we
know the language is decidable so first
of all let's take the two turing
machines m1 and m2 that recognizes a and
a complement
and we're going to put those together
to get a decider for a
um
and that's going to work like this
it's going to be called t
so t says on input w what it's going to
do
it's going to feed w into m1 and m2 both
um a is a language by the way yes a is
when i'm telling you when i say it's
touring recognizable you know turing
recognizable only applies to languages
so so yes a um is often this symbol i'm
going to use for languages sometimes for
an automaton but
a is typically going to be a language
so um
[Music]
if uh so
now i'm trying to make t
be a decider for a
from the recognizers for a and a
complement
so i'm gonna
take an input to t
and feed it into both recognizers m1 and
m2
okay i'm going to run them in parallel
what's nice
is that because
um
m2 is a
recognizes the complement of what m1
recognizes
every string is going to be accepted
either by m1 or by m2
because every string is either an a or
an a complement
so if i run m1 and m2 on w until one of
them holds one of them accepts i know
i'm not going to run forever because
eventually one of the other ones have to
accept
so and then i got my answer because if
m1 accepts that i know i'm in the
language but if m2 accepts i know i'm in
the complement of the language no matter
the language so if m1 accepts then t
should accept if m2 accepts then t
should reject
um
now
so that proves that
nice little theorem uh written at the
top in blue
um so i got my decider for a
built out of the recognizers for a and a
complement
now immediately it follows that
the complement of atm is not touring
recognizable
because
we know
that atm itself
is recognizable but it's undecidable
if its complement were also on recognize
if the complement was also recognizable
then atm would be decidable but it isn't
so when something is
undecidable either it or its complement
have to be unrecognizable and in the
case for atm it has to be the compliment
because we already showed that it is
itself is recognizable
um
so that's the proof of that so here is a
little picture of the way the world
looks right now if you have here in the
middle of the decidable languages see
these are all languages here this venn
diagram of languages kind of we showed
earlier you know like the regular the
context free decidable recognizable
here i've got the recognizable and what
i'm calling the co
co code touring recognizable
this is the collection of all
complements
of recognizable languages so atm
bar atm complement is the complement of
a recognizable language this uh
region here is are all the complements
of the recognizable languages or the
so-called
co-turing recognizable languages
complement of
so atm is on this side atm complement is
on that side but if something's in both
by virtue of this theorem here then it's
decidable
okay
last check-in for the day
um from what we've learned so far
um which closure properties can we prove
for the class of
the touring recognizable languages
choose all that apply
well as i say
you don't have to get it right let's
let's not spend too much more time on
this because we'll we'll we'll talk a
little bit about it
um
almost all it's closed under almost all
of them but not all of them
because you know
are we done here i think we're done
five seconds
okay here we go ending polling
i'm not sure what the meaning of
the leading answer is here uh everybody
likes union i guess they're closed under
all of these operations except
complement so
um
but we just proved it's not closing the
confidence i'm a little
you know a little puzzled by why we have
so many votes for closure under
compliment
uh we have here atm
is touring recognizable but atm
complement is not touring recognizable
so right here on the slide
so i'm not trying to make you feel bad
but uh
um i'm trying to
just point out that you
think please um
so
um
now closure under union and intersection
i mean you could kind of get those
answers just by running things in
parallel the way we did the proof here
you just run both machines
and
if they both
give i mean it's a little tricky i
suppose you know if if if either one of
them accept um
then you can accept or if they both
accept you just wait until they both
have accepted otherwise you just keep
running um so the first two are pretty
straightforward um closure under
concatenation is also going to be
similar you just try every possible way
of cutting uh the string up into two
pieces
and run in parallel on and if you ever
find a way
of cutting it up and you run those two
and those two sides in parallel and if
they both um accept
um then uh then you can accept and star
is again very similar so there these are
not too bad um but i admit you know it's
not a whole lot of time to i have to
contend with something uh that you're
just getting uh used to
so let's um
uh
let's talk about the very last topic of
the day which is really going to be
setting ourselves up
for um tuesday's lecture next week um
and that's
how we are going to be showing other
languages are undecidable which is
something that
um i'm going to be expecting you guys to
be able to do um
this is um
the standard procedure for showing
languages are undecidable using what's
called the reducibility method
um
and what that does is it
takes as a starting point a language
that we already know is undecidable
typically atm
or it could be another one that you've
previously shown to be undecidable and
leverages that information to show other
languages are undecided
and um
it's using what's called reducibility
we're going to go into this
more carefully next time
but basically reducibility is a way of
using one problem to solve another
problem
and so we're going to show for example
uh let's take a look at the problem
called the holding the halting problem
which is like the famous problem for
turing machines um
uh you just want to know whether it
holds not necessarily whether it accepts
so it's very similar but not exactly the
same
and we're going to show that
this halting problem is similarly
undecidable now we could go back and do
the whole diagonalization but that seems
like
well that's more work than necessary now
that we already know atm is undecidable
because we're going to show that we can
reduce the atm
problem to the hold holding problem um
and we'll explain what that means again
uh later but um the idea is and as as
we'll show in an illustration uh shortly
that
by proving by contradiction um
if the whole thing if halt tm
were decidable then atm would be
decidable
and we know atm is not decidable and so
um
that's our contradiction
now
uh
the way we're going to show that if
whole team is decidable than atm is
decidable
is use a decider for whole tm to decide
atm with a suitable
um
you know uh
uh
modification
so basically we're gonna turn
and hold tm decider into an atm decider
and that's
how we're going to reduce the problem of
solving atm to the problem of solving
halt tm
let's just do an example like you know
if you've seen it before obviously this
is not going to be hard but for the many
of you who have not seen it before i it
i'm partly doing it this time just so we
can do it again next time and maybe
it'll sink in by virtue of repetition
so
um
so again so as i just said we're going
to assume the whole tm problem is
decidable and use that to show that atm
is decidable which we know is false we
showed it just earlier that it's not
so assume we have a decider for whole
team we'll call it r
and we're going to construct from our
decider for atm we'll call s
okay so we're again typical proof by
contradiction we're assuming the
opposite of what we're trying to prove
and then we're going to get something
crazy
okay so here my job now is i'm assuming
i have r which is a whole tm decider so
now i'm assuming i know how to
decide
if a turing machine and an input
eventually halts
not necessarily except just whether it
holds
you know it's conceivable you know you
have to bear with me here it's
conceivable that you could find a way to
test whether
you know turing machines halt on their
input even though we now know that
testing whether they accept their input
is not decidable
so you have to kind of be open-minded to
the possibility that we can
that the whole problem is decidable and
we're going to show that that's can't be
so we're going to show that
if we could decide the whole thing
problem then we can use that to decide
the uh the acceptance problem
okay so how do we how do we going to do
that so imagine now we can solve the
halting problem
so to solve the atm
which is what my job is
to do
so s is supposed to solve atm
i'm constructing two
machine as the site atm
i'm going to use first i'm given an mnw
i'm going to feed it into r since that's
really all i got
see if r
tells me
what happens
does m on w at least hold
well if r says no it doesn't hold
well then then i'm actually done
because if it m doesn't even hold on w
then it couldn't be accepting w so at
that point i know that m doesn't accept
w and i can reject right
off
so our you can see how it could
potentially be helpful but it's going to
be helpful in either way because if r if
r says m
does hold
well then i'm also good
because i don't know the answer yet but
what i do know is i can now simulate m
on w
until it holds because r has told me it
holds so i don't have to worry about
getting into a loop
um
uh so s can be confident in being a
decider for whatever it's doing um
because i'm running uh now m on w with a
guarantee that it holds
um
and now that going to tell me now
eventually the simulation of m w is
going to end up at an acceptor reject
and that's going to be the answer i need
so if m is accepted then accept and as m
is rejected then reject
and that's how s solves the atm using r
which which solves whole tia
but s can't exist
and so therefore r can't exist and
therefore whole tm can't be decidable
okay
so that quickly
um
okay
i'm not sure which diagram you wanted me
to show but anyway maybe we can do that
we're basically at the end of the hour
or end of that 90 minutes so let's do a
quick review and if you stick around i'm
happy to go back and look at any of the
other slides uh that you might have
missed something on
okay so just to recap we showed that
uh the natural numbers of the real
numbers are not the same size using that
definition of one-to-one correspondence
to introduce the diagonalization method
we use the diagonalization method to
show that atm is undecidable
we also showed that little theorem that
if the language and its complement are
recognizable then the language is
decidable
and from that we conclude that atm
complement is not recognizable
and then we showed at least by virtue of
an introduction to the method the
reducibility method to show that whole
tm is undecided
okay and that's that that was today's
lecture and we're and we're uh
at the end of the hour so why don't i um
you know we are finished uh you can uh
log out um and if you want i will stick
around
okay
okay this is kind of a good question
here
[Music]
so i'm getting a question about the
atm complement
which is uh you know since we have a
a recognizer for atm
uh if i'm doing justice to this uh
question uh we have a co we have a
recognizer for atm so why can't we just
invert the answer
you know
flip flip the answer around and now we
have a recognizer for
the complement of atm atm complement
so why doesn't that work
well the reason that doesn't work
is because
the recognizer for atm
might be rejecting some things by
looping
and now if you just flip
the accepting and rejecting
um
when it hits one of those uh holding
states it's going to give the reverse
answer
but the uh when it uh
rejects by looping it'll continue to
reject by looping so you won't get the
complementary language coming out
so you know if we want you know if we
would be helpful i can go back
to that uh slide here
um
which proves that atm complement is
unrecognizable
because
maybe we should start with the bottom
we know that atm
is recognizable and undecidable
right we already proved those two facts
atm is recognizable
from the um universal turing machine
and it's undecidable by the
diagonalization argument
those two things together
tell us that the complement has to be
unrecognizable
because
if a language and its complement are
both recognizable and we already know
the language itself is recognizable
so now if the complement is also
recognizable the language is going to be
decidable by the upper theorem
so it must be the case that either the
language itself is unrecognizable or its
complement is unrecognizable
we know the language is recognizable
that's what the universal turing machine
told us so the only thing left is for
the complement to be unrecognizable
you should review that if you didn't get
it um because
this is a kind of
you know
kind of reasoning we
you know we're going to be building on
things like that so i think it's good
good to make sure you understand
okay um
okay the diagram on the right so this is
just a venn diagram here
kind of threw this in at the last minute
here i was worried about it being
confusing
you know that part is um
you know so you know i'm trying to show
that the three classes that we've
already talked about
the languages which are decidable the
languages which are touring recognizable
and the languages whose compliments are
going recognizable those are three
separate classes of languages
and
those come up here in those three
regions
these are the decidable ones
here are the recognizable ones
and here are the ones whose compliments
are recognizable
now if a language
is in both
recognizable and its complement is
recognizable so it's in both of these
bigger regions here
then this theorem tells you it's
decidable
so that's why
the intersection of these two regions is
marked as being decidable because that
means you're in both
okay
but we know that atm is sitting out here
as recognizable but not decidable so atm
is in the recognizable side but it's not
on the complement of recognizable atm
itself um
the complement of atm is the complement
of a recognizable but itself is not
recognizable um
and uh
not decidable so you get this side of
nice
you know
[Music]
i hope it's you think it's nice but it's
a sort of uh trying to summarize things
in this in this field diagram
so i think i'm going to then uh
sign off
and um
i'll see you all on
tuesday and have a good weekend bye-bye